there was a recent blog post on the
Washington Post about essentially slope
and and how Khan Academy talks about it
and and we are big fans of when they're
there is this type of discussion in in
the public but the math in the blog post
was actually very very very wrong and so
I thought this was a good opportunity to
to go over it and hopefully reinforce
our understanding of the idea of slope
so these are excerpts right over here
and says take khan's explanation of
slope which he defines as rise over run
an effective math teacher will point out
that rise over run isn't the definition
of slope at all but merely a way to
calculate it that that statement is
actually wrong the definition of slope
and I got this from Wolfram and if you
go to pretty much any any credible
mathematical site it will define slope
is rise over run this is the definition
of slope this isn't just any regular
equal sign there that is a triple equal
sign and triple equal signs a triple
equal sign in this context literally
means by definition the definition of
slope is change in Y over change in X
it's a change in the vertical axis over
the change in the horizontal axis it's
not just a one change of variable with
respect to another change it's
explicitly a change in the vertical axis
relative to the horizontal axis so if
you think of it this way change in Y if
you're going if you're taking the slope
between this point and this point right
over here how much is why changed well
it's changed that much and how much has
exchanged how much has exchanged well
it's changed that much and so it's
literally change in Y over change in X
or another way to think about it is how
much you have risen over how much you
have run over how much you have run this
is the definition of slope and then the
rest of the statement in fact slope is a
rate that describes how two variables
change in relation to each other how
cars distance changes over time how the
price of an iPod changes as you buy more
memory and this is also kind of wrong a
slope can represent a rate of change if
but it depends on what which variable is
plotted on which axis slope is dependent
it's kind of you it's a visual thing it
really is
it's the vertical axis over the
horizontal axis especially when we're
talking about talking about the scenario
in two dimensions and to see that we
could take one of these examples so say
how the price how the price of an iPod
changes as you buy more memory if we
plot price on the x-axis let's call it P
and if we plot memory all right let's
list right let call it well write mem so
we don't confuse it with this the slope
variable so if we all just call it
memory I'll just write the whole thing
I'm stare price and memory price and the
memory so if this is how it's plotted if
this just shows you how much memory you
can get as you keep RF as you as you're
willing to pay more then actually this
right over here will not be the slope
the price changes as you buy more more
memory will not be the slope and so let
me just make this clear change in price
how the price changes as you buy as the
memory changes this would not be slope
in this context if they are plotted in
this way this right over here is not
this is not slope so in this context
that statement would actually be wrong
in this context the slope would be how
memory changes as price changes so in
this context it's literally how much
does the vertical axis change is going
to be change in memory change in memory
over change in price this is what this
is explicitly what the slope is by
definition in this context it cannot be
this so it actually be very confusing
for student to learn slope as merely
this it is how much the vertical axis
changes for a change in the horizontal
axis and then later in the post to talk
about discussing whether slope always
requires units whether slope should
always require units and this is
especially slope can have units as we go
in this situation memory / price or
distance per time or something like this
but slope definitely doesn't always
require units and especially kind of in
the most pure sense of what a slope is
even trying to measure and to do that I
have a little picture of an actual ski
slope and if you were there and you said
well how steep is this and that really
is the motivation for the whole idea of
slope and why it's even call
slope is really thinking about well
house deep is this how what's the grade
of this surface well if you were doing
this you would say well how high if I if
I go in the horizontal direction a
certain bit and that the amount that I
drew right there looks about 10 meters
how much does my surface increase in the
vertical direction that is what slope is
all about and so the way it looks here
that looks like it goes up about I don't
know I'd guess that's about 3 that's
about 3 meters and so the slope here
literally is the rise over the run how
much we change in the vertical axis over
the horizontal axis so the slope of this
ski slope the slope of this right over
here let me write it so the slope right
over here and I'll put the units in here
to show that they cancel out that the
slope is actually unit list even though
we are explicitly talking about
distances the slope where these skiers
are hanging out would be equal to if we
assume these numbers your change in the
vertical direction which is 3 meters
over the change in the horizontal
direction which is 10 meters and so the
meters cancel out and so the slope even
though we started with distances is a
pure and you end unit list value of 3
tens so it's actually it's actually
ridiculous to say that slope always
requires units